hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be giving you guys the
advice that i wish i had when i was like
16 or 17. but before i begin
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe especially subscribe
i'm trying to hit 15 000 subscribers
guys and i know
that i have the support to do it i know
i do so don't forget hit that subscribe
button
but the first piece of advice that i
would give a young me
is to maintain your weight i know
body positivity body acceptance is a
thing i totally understand it
i don't want people to be unconfident in
who they are and how they look
however life is harder if you're
overweight
if you're out of shape it is harder to
do things
it is harder to attract guys to go on
dates with you
everything is harder so
look at maintaining your weight as a
full-time job because if you can
maintain your high school weight
i promise you your life will be easier
because it is harder
to lose weight than it is just to
maintain it
so weigh yourself every day maintain
your weight
number two do not take advice from
anyone that you would not trade
places with do not take relationship
advice
from anyone that's not in a serious
relationship if your goal is to get
married and be in a serious relationship
and you're taking advice from single
people
don't do not because a lot of those
women do not have your best intentions
at heart the women that are telling you
to just do what you want the women that
are telling you that it's empowering to
be
i'm not going to go into it to be like
[ __ ] and stuff
it's not empowering a lot of them just
don't want to be alone in their bad
decisions
do not listen to anyone you would not
want to trade places with
piece of advice number three do not get
into binge drinking it is not worth it
if you find yourself partying going out
all the time
it is because you have a void in your
life and you need to do some
self-reflection
and figure out why you have that void
you're not going to
learn anything at these parties you're
not going to become a better person at
these parties
find something that you are passionate
about and you would rather do
than go to a party piece of advice
number four
is to stop caring so much about what
other people think
half of these people you are never gonna
see again like you will never see them
on a daily basis
they don't matter you know who you
should care
about what they think care about what
your parents think care about what your
close friends think
but does it matter if
everyone likes you no it doesn't
find something that make that you're so
passionate about that you don't
care if people don't like you piece of
advice number five
figure out what you like to do by trying
everything
you never know what you like to do until
you try
a bunch of things and figure it out